alors c'est un pote et une blonde qui
parle
je suis pas bien mais attends
franchement il y a la pharmacie à côté
ils ont fait un truc extraordinaire il y
a une espèce d'ordinateur tu mets tes
urines dedans il te dit exactement ce
que c'est tu vois ok le mec un peu
sceptique c'est Ricardo tu peux y aller
ça va faire mal tu dis que tu viens de
Samantha il y a aucun problème
donc le mec qui va tu vois il est un peu
bon il pisse dans le truc il arrive à la
pharmacie ils vont un espèce
d'ordinateur comme ça
ça a l'air d'être pas donc il met son
aimer son urine bon
[Rires]
vous avez une tendinite au coude
évitez de les charges lourdes et mettez
votre coude dans l'eau chaude très
régulièrement et le mec il est un peu
con il dit waouh c'est un truc de fou ça
met alors attends j'aimerais bien faire
une connerie avec l'ordi la machine j'ai
rien tenter un truc tu vois qu'est-ce
qu'il fait il prend utile la petite
fiole il dit attends je vais retourner
on va faire une blague il va voir chérie
tu as pas envie de pisser par hasard
ouais monsieur ouais tiens vas-y même un
petit peu de pissouille